everyone how's everyone doing hope
you're doing fine Sunday I hope
everybody's grabbing their beer ready
for a little chat on a very exciting
subject today today we're gonna be doing
lying geometric line how I'm more
exciting and mad can it get now you
might wonder and say you know don't you
have a more interesting subject to talk
about yeah I guess it's not a very
exciting subject very energetic subject
but we need to cover it and we need to
cover it because what happens is the
mathematicians mathematical physicists
they use the point and they use the line
they extrapolate that those geometric
concepts and they extrapolate them over
into general relativity and quantum
mechanics you've probably heard about
the point particle right what are
particles how do you visualize them
well you visualize them is a little
point whatever a point is but now we got
to go back to Euclid or whatever but
that's what they show they show a point
that's what they draw that's what they
put on the board that's what they
illustrate and so you need to get a
handle on you know what a point is what
the definition is what it is and where
it came from where did we get this word
point and likewise with the line you
know the line of underlies general
relativity primarily because the line
stands for distance for length for
geodesic you know they talk about a
straight line in four-dimensional space
well you know those are the geodesics
they're curved in our world but over
there they're straight lines I guess I
don't know maybe it's the other way
around
they have all these notions so we need
to get a handle on what are they talking
about are they talking about a line are
they talking about a geometric figure is
that what these people are talking about
that's why you know you got a rehash
what Euclid did and what everybody all
his inheritors all his disciplines did
you know thousands of years after him
you know where do they stand on these
famous words on these concepts right
that they're going to be using so yeah
it's for most people it's not a very
exciting subject but it's like we got to
cover that base someone's got to do it I
got to do the dirty work you know I mean
I'm sorry someone's got to do it before
I start I just wanna one more time I'll
try to remind people constantly I want
to remind people that we have the
rational physics conference the seventh
rational physics conference in Bora
Sweden so I just want to remind you
every now and then hopefully every every
time so that you buy your plane tickets
make reservations you know plan ahead
don't wait till the last moment if
you're really interested in coming in
there you're gonna meet some very
interesting people and would like to
talk a lot about the rope model and
physics and also about extinction and
yeah we get to extinction after we had
the beers usually that's the way it
typically works and that's going to be
on June 8 2009 teen we're still
organizing it but it will it will be
done
for sure we're gonna have it so you know
get your plane tickets ready get your
air BnB ease whatever you're gonna we
have here one of the sponsors and he
says Boris really I hope I pronounced
that well Martin Boris I hope that's you
you won't kill me for pronouncing
mispronouncing that says Boris literally
translates to living rich living living
rich I see okay so we're going to the
living
age to drink beer now hopefully the
Swedish beer is as good as we've seen it
everywhere else so far you know so we'll
find out what we get there
anyways I want to get on with the line
why do we mess around with a line why do
we care about a line well again because
mathematical physics makes good use of a
line you know they they do borrow it
heavily and not only the line they
borrow the point and the line in fact I
would say they borrow the point more
than they borrow the line but they do
borrow these objects or comp concepts
we'll find out today but whatever they
are whether a concept an object a figure
or an itinerary or whatever it is they
do borrow it and they apply it and they
convince you of their theories so this
is not a matter to be taken lightly
because their theories are founded on
these notions of point and line we cover
the point last time and maybe I should
do a review later on with both the line
and the and the point but today I'd like
to concentrate on the line we've got
enough material there for today okay so
let's get started if if we want to start
with a line where do you go well we go
to mr. Euclid Euclid of Alexandria and
what Euclid did 300 years before Christ
more or less that's that's the best they
can locate him we don't have a much
information on his life or anything like
that but we know he he worked at the
Library of Alexandria and that's about
it and then he created the elements
which was later borrowed by the Arabs
and they developed it even further or or
polished it up or whatever they they
studied Euclid as well and then we
inherited all that stuff back from the
Arabs kind of you know you could give it
to the the Greeks gave it to the Arabs
the Arabs gave it to us to our West us
Westerners I consider myself a
Westerners because that's right was born
and lived so they gave it to us
and yeah 300 years before Christ Euclid
came up with he didn't really come up
with it by the way you know he he kind
of made a he organized the thoughts of
the Greeks whatever they had discovered
until then until 300 years before Christ
whatever they had invented whatever they
had developed as far as geometry
whatever they had you know whatever
rules whatever laws whatever definitions
whatever axioms they had developed or
evolved or whatever by then he kind of
put them together in this book elements
the elements and and that's what we got
we got his book whether there was a book
before his well we don't know and there
probably wasn't maybe he's the guy who
finally sat down and said I'm gonna
write all this down and and you know put
that in some kind of order so that you
know all these thoughts are running
around by different mathematicians we
can condense them in one book so this is
like the encyclopedia of geometry you
could say his elements and that's where
we get our starting point so from that
starting point we look at his
definitions and this is what we find we
find that he's got a set of definitions
with which he begins his book and today
we're going to look at definition number
two a line is breathless length big
words breathless length
he also says later on definition for a
straight line is a line okay so a
straight line is a special kind of line
again apparently under the word line he
includes you know curbs and you might
also think of this because he says
breathless length if he's talking about
curves a circle a circumference or the
circumference of a circle you know if
that's included because we're talking
about curves
in also lies well here you have a line
that begins and ends so it's got a
beginning and an end it ends where it
begins essentially so I'm not sure that
would be infinite right but here he's
referring to breathless like meaning not
that the length extends eternally but
that that it's one dimensional
that's what breathless stands for okay
he's in and again we have to be careful
on how these people translate these
things okay this this was translated as
breathless length what is the problem
that I see with that right off the bat
well the problem is this word breath
breath lusts okay breath is sideways
motion that's what the word breath means
not all languages have it like they
don't have it in German and we don't
have it in Spanish either you know I
know those two languages for sure I can
tell you they don't have breath they use
the word with essentially to refer to
breath and breath is and it's very hard
to pronounce that but okay breath is
different than width and it's different
than latitude these are three different
kind of words and I'm gonna go over that
later in another presentation on
dimensions right but just just for your
information right now breath is sideways
motion that's different than width which
is just a dimension in a horizontal
plane and that's different than latitude
which is a coordinate for locating
things along a horizontal plane so these
are three different concepts and so
whoever translated the breathless part
in Euclid's definition he should have
said with less
length
and he should have said to be more
clearly he should have said hi + + width
+ length because dimensions come in
three flavors they come in length width
and height you need all three of them
you know there is no such thing as
length without width or height there's
no such thing as hike without width or
length there's no such thing as width
without letter length or height you need
all three of them because that's what a
three dimensional object is and all
existing objects are three dimension and
again I don't want to get ahead of
myself and talking about dimensions
although I just want you to be aware
where all this stuff comes from you know
or to keep these things in mind breath
it was the wrong word to use okay the
best he could have done whoever did this
translation would have been with less
length but essentially he's saying that
it's got no thickness right no width no
height really its height list but that's
what I want to say not worthless but hey
it doesn't have any thickness to it and
it's just length without the height
right and really it would have been
better to say tightness with and I hope
you don't have a headache right now
anyways the wording is important in that
sense then the other thing about that is
that you know if it's breathless length
what was he referring to is length a
physical object is that is length a
geometric figure and the answer is no
obviously if if Euclid was talking about
length he was talking about something
else I mean is length the same thing as
a line
are they synonyms you know here here I
have Euclid's breathless length you see
it there mr. Euclid I is writing it for
the first time
you can see what he's writing there on
the right-hand side he's writing a line
a B okay fine that mine as I can show
you there is got hit with and it's got
height it's got two dimensions at least
so that's what what the what that line
that you can drew on the board or on his
piece of paper or in his book or
whatever that's what he would have to
draw if he if he's gonna represent it
and then you can say yeah okay the line
is a geometric figure I'll repeat that
figure yeah it's a geometric figure it's
got width and height so far no problem
but that's how a Euclid's saying that's
what he drew on the board that's what a
mathematician or geometers draws under
board but what is it that they say they
say it's breathless length
they're saying it's a length but length
is not a is not a stick and no wonder
it's breathless in other words why is it
one-dimensional that's what breathless
means that's what Euclid was referring
to that it's one-dimensional okay and so
if if the length is one-dimensional
actually it's non-dimensional that would
be a more accurate description of length
it's a concept and concepts don't have
dimensions they don't have thickness
they don't have with they don't have
height they don't have anything because
they're their concepts and if length is
a concept you know we've got a problem
to say first that it's breathless that
that was uncalled-for
he should have say said a line is length
that's all you needed to say and if a
line is length okay then
length is not a geometric figure so now
we have our problem because Euclid is
setting the foundations for for geometry
and he's telling us in so many words
that this is a geometric figure and he's
gonna define it as length that's what
the problem is he's treating a
except as a physical object and that's
why you know we're gonna run into
trouble not only with Euclid but as
you'll see today well we're gonna run
into trouble with everyone that came
afterwards because one is a concept the
other one is an object one is a figure
and the other one is an eight inner a
verb and that's where the problem is you
know you could qualify to his life but
he's not talking about a geometric
figure in that case and he has not laid
down the foundations of geometry the
other one is that he insinuates that
this thing continues forever
you know and that's what it's gonna come
down to us through the ages that a line
you know is it's just infinite in both
directions so they put you know I put on
me in his little grinder and his I'm not
sure if that's what you could intended
but that's what it is today that the
line is infinite in both direction which
means that you know if you cleat
intended that that the line doesn't stop
we don't have a geometric figure either
in that case because if the line
continues to positive infinity or the
negative infinity whatever that is it
just means it's still growing and if
it's a line and if it's got to be a
figure it's got to have endpoints and
here you'll see it in his in his
definitions okay here you see it if you
look at definition number fourteen down
at the bottom there a figure is that
which is contained by any boundary okay
so if it's contained by a boundary and
the line is infinite then the line the
line at the even if it's even if it's a
rectangle and elongated rectangle if
it's doesn't have if it's infinite then
that means it's still growing it means
it doesn't have endpoints it is not
bounded it does not have a boundary and
so we have to determine you know you
Euclid is is really referring to you
know if if he is referring to an object
or to an itinerary because we can
imagine walking running jumping that can
be forever that we're talking about a
verb something that goes out forever we
we can all maybe picture that the movie
doesn't end okay endless love but here
here we're talking about something else
we're saying that if Euclid's line is
endless in both directions or even in
one direction starts here but never ends
then he hasn't finished constructing his
line he's still in the business of
building it in fact his disciplines
should still be constructing it at one
point at a time you know they're still
continuing going on and on and on so we
got a problem we got a problem because
it means that we're not talking about
geometric figure we're really referring
to an itinerary and what they're saying
is that itinerary is not stopped we're
talking about perpetual motion that's
what we're talking about and perpetual
motions not a geometric figure so keep
that in mind okay what happens next well
you know hopefully someone did better
than you clear I mean that was 2,300
years ago maybe a little more a little
less and I mean we had all this time mm
here's us 2,300 centuries since Euclid -
to improve on his work surely someone
has done a lot better right well the
answer is no the answer is we still are
using Euclid's line to this day that's
what we have in geometry how do they
state it they say that a line is
undefined
they can't define what a line is say
what do you mean after 2300 years you
can't define the word learning they said
no we can't because it's a primitive
concept oh okay
primitive concept
Oh exactly you mean by that well it
means that you know you have to start at
some point like the ABCs geometry in
this case the foundations and you know
we can talk about solids but solids have
to be based on a previously defined
structure for example you can say the
plane and a plane has to be defined
founded the foundation of the plane has
to be founded on something previously
any findings in this case would be the
line but I would have to be defined
based on a previous geometric object or
concept called the point but if that
argument holds first of all we got a
little problem because it means that it
means that we already have a starting
point that's the point so if you can say
okay I'm not going to define the point
because you know it's the it's the what
constitutes everything else
okay well let's concede that now you
don't have an excuse for line because
the line is made of points and you don't
have an excuse for planes because the
plane is made out of lines and points
and you don't have an excuse or solids
because they're made out of planes lines
and points and the answer they'll give
you today is that points lines and
planes all three of them are undefined
so they don't know what a plane is they
don't know what a line is they don't
know what a point is and the excuses
that you know we need something more
primitive okay so you got it's the point
right what's your what's your Excuse now
so that's the first argument yet said
the other one is that you know you in
physics in the world of rationality in
science we don't define we define
concepts we don't define objects you
don't define figures you point to them
okay you got the Martian coming over you
want to teach him your language you got
to start with the nouns like I said last
time
then you points a table a couch lamp you
point a name that's how you designate or
that's how you you know come up with a
language of nouns of figures you don't
define a table
you don't say a table has you know four
legs and you know board over it that's
not a table a table is what you pointed
to then you can describe it but first
you got to point to it in naming and so
that's that's the starting point the
starting point here is that Euclid is
supposed to point and not be fine you
should make a drawing what do you mean
by point I mean that's what I mean by
point oh okay that's a synonym of a dot
then we all understand that's what's
staring at you in the face you're saying
okay I died but then he can't say well
by the way the dot is zero dimension
what it means you're mentioned it's got
two dimensions width and height
what do you mean the line is one
dimensional it's got width and height I
see two two dimensions now that's a
pictorial representation of the real
line the real line is something else
it's a length and so now we have a
problem
and it turns out it's not even a length
and that's what I'm gonna cover next
here we have mr. Herman whale a guy who
I've studied a little bit in some detail
and mr. Herman and he wrote a book
called what's my line now that's a lie
now he wrote a book called space time
and matter and in space time and matter
if you look at this book he starts out
by laying the foundations of geometry he
goes over the foundations of geometry as
a as an introduction to general
relativity the book is about general
relativity and he was a colleague of
Einstein he went to Princeton
so Hermann you know in fact he died I
think it the same year they both died in
1955 I think it was so you know they
knew each other and they probably worked
together etc and it's important to know
that I
9:1 said that all all his college I
don't know he singled out whale but all
his colleagues they treated him like an
old piece of furniture they they all got
away from him like from the left leprosy
you know from from a leper they treated
him as a crank the last years of his
life and yeah I am whale he well he
wrote his book in 1929 so that's when
Einstein was still you know roaring it's
when I signed later I went to Princeton
and was with whale that he was treated
like a piece of furniture where people
you know avoided him in the hallways and
we always probably one of those I don't
know because whale continued to believe
in general relativity Einstein as far as
I'm concerned did not no longer believed
in general relativity he he essentially
like he's told his friend Bayes oh he
didn't believe in you know he stopped
believing in the field concept the
concept called field which is what he
was famous for you know he never got a
Nobel Prize where he was famous for
inventing the field equations 1915 1916
okay so what does mr. will say as far as
what a line is oh very simple
he says looked a line is two points okay
he says the straight line he starts out
with us already on page 12 you know it's
uh
he goes over Euclidean space as they
call it Euclidean geometry which is
two-dimensional geometry essentially and
he says the straight line is determined
by two of its points page 12 and there
you have the two-point line
they call it the line a B here you have
two points and the question is whether
that's aligned if you look at the lower
left you see a red and blue dot there
and then to the right of that you see a
solid one-piece stick black state if you
show those two images to a kindergartner
and say could you identify which of
these two images is a line which one do
you think he would choose which one
would you choose
yeah I think we would all choose the one
on the right the one on the left a
two-point line
I don't know doesn't look like a line to
me it looks like two balls okay looks
like King Kong ping pong balls that's
what it looks like ping pong King Kong's
balls okay so that was his first
introduction into the word line right
he's trying to define what a line is
next he continues with the the distance
the length line of Euclid he goes like
this
he says the straight line lies even be
between its points so let's assume for
the sake of argument that points is
refers to two objects two figures we'll
just assume that and we'll consider the
points as being dots okay he what build
is saying is that the straight line lies
evenly between its points okay if he's
referring to length we got a problem
because we got the breathless length and
besides that we have in other words a
one-dimensional length and length is a
concept so it's not even one-dimensional
it's it's non-dimensional concepts don't
have dimensions so you can see on the
bottom right breathless like the arrow
points to nothing that's what the whales
distance line looks like or length line
looks like if on the other hand how we
define length as a distance we're not
even talking about length we're talking
about empty space between two dots which
is the image on the lower left so which
is it
are we talking about is is the straight
line the the distance between two points
is a straight line a one-dimensional
length or better yet a non-dimensional
length what what are we saying when we
say that it lies evenly between its
points and then of course if you add to
this that the word point means zero
dimensional nothing there is the point
it is not a dot a point is a location
we're talking about the distance or the
length between two locations whatever
that could possibly mean we're talking
total abstractions here and this is
supposed to be you know the the
foundations of these are supposed to be
the foundations of geometry what is
geometry the study or the research or
the science of shapes and sizes to begin
with you need a shape and you need
something in there and these people are
forgetting just about the somethings and
they're working with nothing's they're
working with concepts okay that's where
they start okay
what's the next notion that mr. whale
comes up with and again these are new
concepts that came after Euclid okay
these were developed after you you could
probably did not have any idea of some
of these notions that were you know
popped into geometry later on and this
is the hinge okay here mr. whale says
not only the straight line but also the
plane is based on a property of rotation
and when you look at his book what whale
is talking about is the fact that if you
rotate a line as long as every point
remains on the line then you have what
is called a congruent transformation
okay so so the line doesn't get twisted
or bent or warped or whatever okay but
he talks about rotation now we're
talking about the motion of planes and
lines
he's treating it like you know a hinge
or that goes around a stick they think
about hinge that goes completely around
right a stick run through the center and
the the rotation of the hinge determines
the straightness of the line and the
definition of the line that serves as a
as a stick inside you know the hinge so
that's another notion okay let's look at
another notion here this is my favorite
one because this is this is the one
that's probably used but one of the ones
that's use the most and that's the row
of apples now we have you know the row
of apples line and here a whale says a
Congress transformation which transforms
a into itself and all points to the
right of a into points to the right of a
and all points to the left of a into
points to the left of a leaves every
point on the straight line undisturbed
so he's saying the straight line is made
of points and he confirms that later on
for pages later he says we shall obtain
an array of points on the straight line
under construction okay we got a couple
problems here because whale is not
finished with his line he's constructing
his line and if his line is infinite as
he will say later on you know we're
talking about apples that just go on
forever you know all these pointers go
on forever inand because they construct
lines see in science we don't construct
dogs or trees or or or rocks if we point
to them and it better be a finished
product when you point what these people
are saying you can't point to a circle
you got a constructed point by point and
you can't point to a cube you got a
constructed point by point or plane by
plane or line by line they constrain
geometric figures well give me a call
when you finish sculpture you went when
you finish your your grand you know
sculpture give me a call so I can see
your finished product right now you're
still working on it
especially if you tell me that the line
is infinite you haven't finished your
line and then you can't even call it a
geometric figure because like mr. Euclid
says you know you know if this thing
continues forever then you know what are
we talking about we talking about length
are we talking about an itinerary are we
talking about locations that go on
forever because we're not talking about
really a line we're talking about a
kangaroo that's jumping from point to
point and he's still running you know
he's still jumping which means that you
know from from a geometric point of view
what all these people are saying when
they say especially when they say that
their line is infinite they're talking
about motion they're not talking about a
perimeter or a surface of a geometric
figure that you can put your finger at
that's what I'm saying but these people
are referring to something else they're
referring to all these points which
represent locations and what is location
we're talking about not locations of
different apples in this case we had
that but we got another one which is let
me show that first maybe here we have
the itinerary line this is the other
version of of the many apples but here
we have one Apple and we're talking
about the translation of an apple in
other words well says let a be a
translation which transfers the point a
to a subzero to a so he's talking about
you know translate he's talking about
moving one Apple not about a robe of
that apples and he says the straight
line is
right from a point by an infinite
repetition infinite repetition of the
same infinitesimal translation and its
inverse okay so so what whale is saying
here is that you know not only is the
Apple at different locations we're only
talking about one Apple here okay and
the Apple is a different location that's
rolling it's moving it's sliding it's
whatever it's doing and it goes on
forever because he's talking about an
infinite repetition and the other one
that you should keep in mind is the word
infinitesimal I hate to spend all day on
that word but it kind of but I'm just
gonna give you a forewarning on that
infinitesimally small
that's what's infinite testimony pnes
and so how small is small I mean what is
this infinitesimal translation how far
am I supposed to move that Apple am I
supposed to move in an inch or is that
too much maybe I'll move it just a
centimeter how about a micrometer or how
about an angstrom you know I need to
know how far I'm gonna move that he says
infinitesimal but by infinitesimally he
really means zero which is what all
mathematicians want to convey with a
word infinitesimal when they say
infinitesimally it's it's a buzz word
that should immediately shocked you
because you know you should keep an ear
for it
infinitesimal in mathematics mean zero
that's what they want to me see you have
the limit as X approaches zero
well approaches doesn't mean zero
infinitesimal means approaches it
doesn't mean zero that you're standing
at zero and these people use you know
dualities they love dualities they say
infinite essence of proaches zero X
approaches zero but you know it's also
zero so whenever they use the word
infinitesimal most of the time when
they're talking qualitative stuff they
mean zero they mean nothing and so
infinitesimal translation but anyways
infinitesimal translate
means it moved and if it moved you're
talking about one Apple covering
different locations okay and that's
different than having you know a row of
apples that's a different concept
altogether and of course is you get
another one similar to that one and yeah
again you can think of this as sliding
so you can jump or you can slide or you
can just transfer the Apple there are
many ways of looking at this this is the
sliding version you slide the Apple
through the rabbits whole gang and it
creates a trough in there okay so he
says there is one and only one
translation which transfers the
arbitrary point a on G to the arbitrary
point a star on the same straight line
okay so he's got this other notion this
the sliding or this prophetís channel
type notion of lying does he stop there
no no he's got a couple more here he's
got the stick which I love - here's the
stick okay here's the stick this will
stick all the points which we obtain
he's taking there the row of apples okay
keep that one in mind all the points
which we obtain finally fuse together
into a linear continuum now you like the
word continuing because continuum is is
a concept which they turn into a noun
they turn this this adjective continues
into a noun and what they mean is that
continuum you're some kind of stick that
is made of a single piece that's what
they call continued and they'll use this
this fancy word and they say in which
they become embedded giving up their
individual existences we no longer have
dots now we have the continuous the
single piece stick okay this description
is founded our in our intuition of
continuity
so you see what whale has done here with
with with the line he took all these
apples and then infused them together
they lose their individuality their
individual existence and he become a
stick of apples all blended into you
know meshed into a single stick but
again if we're talking about a single
stick are we talking about a
two-dimensional stick or are we talking
about motion and itinerary or a series
of locations and yes motion in that
sense you could say is continuous but it
really is not when you come to think of
it motion is discrete because it means
the object is at a second locations at
different location so to so try to make
an image of that here you have the movie
the universal movie if if an object can
only have one location once it is at a
second location I don't care how
infinitesimal that other location is how
far away you put it from its original
location if that if it has a different
location that location should fall in a
different frame of the movie this is a
conceptual issue this is not an issue of
oh let's define this or that that's a
conceptual issue if motion is two or
more locations and we're talking about
motions two or more locations means two
frames of the universal for a film and
so you're talking about two now motion
is always to at least as a minimum and
so if the dot or the location is the two
locations right then you need two frames
of the film in that sense motion is
discrete because location can only be
fit in a picture motion can only be fit
in a movie in a strip of film that's a
conceptual
understood what I'm trying to say here
okay anyways well he blends all this
movie and he forgets about what's in the
frames and he just takes the whole film
strip and he says look I got a line yeah
but how about all the frames that you
have that make up your your filmstrip
you you got all these frames they're
discrete right because each one is
chopped off at the little lines there
that that the frame has and he gets rid
of all that he just blends it into a
single steak but then he tells you again
that you're staring at a 1d line made of
zero dimensional points you figure it
out okay does he stop there now we got
one more and it's you say what else
could could align be alright okay here
we have the final line that he's got
more really but I'm gonna stop here okay
here it is the number line well finally
says okay forget about locations forget
about points forget about apples forget
about one Apple rolling or sliding
forget about turning all the apples into
a steak I'm gonna turn this whole line
I'm gonna take my magic wand and turn it
into a bunch of numbers a series of
numbers and he says if we take all
possible whole numbers as values of n
this area will become denser in
proportion as n increases and he goes on
to if you look at his book you'll you'll
figure out that he just goes on and on
dealing with numbers after that so
whatever he presented at the beginning
has nothing to do with what he's going
to use it for later on especially as a
foundation for gem for general
relativity he's gotta be talking about
distances he's gonna be talking about
lengths not so much about length but
it's sure about surely about distances
because that's what general relativity
deals with you got to talk about
geodesics and he's gonna talk about
numbers
what's any of that got to do with the
stick made of a single piece all these
apples that he blended together and
turned
stick what's one thing got to do with
the other
what does distance length geodesic
numbers what do any of those have to do
with geometry
I thought geometry was a study of shapes
and sizes I don't know about sizes but
certainly about shapes and relations
between shapes and maybe relationships
also between angles you know that kind
of thing but what's all that got to do
with length distances it's your destiny
Ares numbers looks like what does any of
that have to do with geometry and that's
essentially what they're doing they're
creating foundations
now for geometry they're creating
foundations for all the stuff that
they're gonna use for things like
general relativity or string theory
what's a string what's a string string
is vibrating lines a 1d line you can
hook it up don't take my word for it
look up the 1d strings what are they
talking about they're talking about you
know a line and you know that string
Wiggles so you would think it goes into
a second dimension when it Wiggles and
they keep calling it a 1d line so are
they talking qualitative or quantitative
are they saying are they talking about
the length of distance or are they
talking about
Euclid's 1d line I mean what are they
talking about
and again they use the Chiappa the
geometric figure called line the word
line which you know what we mean you
know we we mean that stick that you see
there that we draw on the board but
you're supposed to think of that is 1d
okay I'll even go as far as that and now
they're gonna vibrate it into two
dimensions they say see it's a 1d line a
vibrating 1d line well no as soon as it
moved up it turned into a 2d line you
know it it bent or whatever it work
inside the qualitative stuff just goes
from one ear through the other nothing
in between to stop
okay so let me put all these lines
together so you can see them in one
picture one nice beautiful picture there
and here you have the two-point line is
that aligned to two dots now you would
think the line is more like a stick
right like maybe the one below down
there will stick you would think that's
that's a line that's what kindergartner
would recognize as a line then you have
the in-between line
okay the between two points are we
talking about a distance or are we
talking about a length either way we're
not talking about a stick so that green
part that I drew in there that's
misleading that's false the line that is
between the two points is not a line
it's a it's a distance that's what's
between two points and if you and if he
wants to put something in there he
should draw it and for sure that's not
gonna be one-dimensional or even you
know constructed by serial dimensional
points well since you know you got the
translation the rotation the row of
apples you know that's a neat line they
just put a bunch of points one next to
each other we don't know how close they
are we don't know if they're touching
one with the other how small the points
are because I mean be nice to know how
how big the points are to find out you
know how much space is between their
their bottoms or between like in this
case between the leaf of the Apple okay
and also remember something that each
Apple in order to maintain its
individuality it has to be from a
conceptual point of view it has to be
encapsulated within space you could say
right in other words there's they've got
to be completely isolated from the one
next to it and you know what whale does
at least he takes that it turns it into
a stick he just blends them okay then we
have the rolling apple that's just one
Apple that is at different locations
maybe it rolls maybe it slides like in
the plowing line below you know
maybe it just creates a channel maybe it
just is sent so that it kind of what is
it called the word skipped my mind when
the guy just misses all the space in
between so he's reconstructed at another
location there were just escaped meteor
right now anyways so so it doesn't go
through all the intermediate locations
and then you have the number line you
know all these locations all these
apples are turned into numbers so you
get your pick you've got enough there to
keep you busy what is the line have you
know I mean you go home and your dad
asks you okay son what did you learn in
school today I don't know not much dad
what did you take I took geometry and
what did you what was the subject matter
oh it was the line and what is a line
well that's the point I have no idea
because I mean they have all these
notions of line and most of them except
maybe the stick the row of apples except
those two maybe all the others have
nothing to do with geometry they don't
they're not geometric figures and that's
that's the main problem we're not
talking about geometry anymore and you
say well bill you know I mean you're
cupping or fitting around too much with
language you're doing semantics but see
they're gonna use this later on too as
the underlying foundations of their
theories of general relativity of strain
theory of quantum mechanics that's why
you have to be careful you know then
they end up saying oh what is a particle
it's a vibrating field what is a black
hole oh it's a bunch of mass and what is
the mass well it's just a dot point with
infinite mass
so you gotta be careful because there
you going to use this you know for their
theories it's it's not a trivial issue
and if they're gonna do that okay then
take the trouble to define it properly
then there's the other issue is if
you're going to if you're going to say
look the point is really a location a
line is really an itinerary or a bunch
of numbers whatever you say don't call
it line because you confuse people if
you're if you're lying is a bunch of
location is one location
how's that for it for a revolutionary
proposal use the word locations say you
know I'm not talking about lines I'm not
talking about a stake I'm talking about
a bunch of locations on a plane or on a
or on a solid on a cube that people
understand say oh you're talking about
locations but you call it point or you
call it line you confuse people
completely because people say okay what
do you mean nine are you referring to
the physical object to the to the
two-dimensional stick or are you to
refer you to a bunch of locations are
you referring to an itinerary or are you
referring to a bunch of apples yeah I
mean what are you referring to that's
where it gets confusing because the word
line at that point becomes could be
anything and you guys you know you got
to stay tuned and say what is he
referring to at this moment in time is
he talking about this or that that's
where the problem is okay so let me get
down to the conclusions for today at
least and here we have a little summary
geometers still use Euclid's breathless
length at the definition of line
essentially they're nothing has changed
they still think of line as a
one-dimensional length distance or
itinerary or a bunch of locations
however you want to see that that's what
the word line means today and it had and
if that's what it means it's not it has
nothing to do with geometry
and second if that's what it means that
they should use the word length and not
the word line they should use the word
itinerary not the word line they should
use the you know term like row of apples
a bunch of numbers the number line
whatever they want to you know whatever
they really mean they should not be
confusing you by seeing the line okay
Euclid's line fails because it's
incessant you know it just goes on
forever it's he's really referring to
length or an itinerary really because
length in in Euclidian geometry keep in
mind is distance that they're sending
him and what they're talking about is
measurement they're saying they're gonna
extend the measuring tape and again
we're talking about the itinerary of the
front of the tape that's what length is
in there because they're talking about
measurement they're talking about
numbers are talking about a concept a
mathematical concept okay they're not
talking about the the space between two
tables or the length of a table meaning
you know that extends from here to there
qualitatively now they're talking about
look let's pull out the tape and measure
and oh it measures one meter that one
meter is that length and the separation
between two tables is one meter and a
half well that one meter and a half is
the distance that's why they have
defined distance at length to be
synonyms because to them it's one meter
either way okay is uh according to
Euclid it's one dimensional that's not a
figure because all figures at least are
two-dimensional two-dimensional so if
it's not a figure doesn't even belong in
geometry I would say no if he's
referring to an itinerary he should use
again the word itinerary or bunch of
locations or anything you want but not
the word line and then again location
itinerary numbers are not geometric
figures so he cannot treat him as such
we're talking about concepts there and
not about objects
geometers uh basically whale in this day
and age
he died already but I mean is this
opposed essentially say the same thing
they confess that they don't have a
definition for line no kid we don't
define figures if they're trying to
define the word line then they're
defining a concept we don't define
objects we point to them and name them
you point to a table and say table
that's how you so-called define a table
you point to it and then the et
understands what your what your word
table means and that's the way you
should do with line if line is a
geometric figure if line is something
else then yeah you want to define it and
then yeah of course they're gonna have
trouble defining the word line because
they want to have their duality in there
they want to think they want you to
think that it's a geometric figure the
two-dimensional stick and at the same
time they want you to think of it as an
itinerary that's where they run into
trouble that's why they can't define it
and again we have all these notions that
you saw in mr. whale to point the
distance the length the locations
itineraries numbers none of those are
lines a line is a stick that's what it
is that's what you see there that's what
we objectively have before us that black
line that you see there that's the line
and as you can see it's got height and
width it's got two dimensions if the
geometers can't use that for anything
then they should not call it a line
because that's what a line is and that's
the border of a square and that's a
border of a cube you know those are the
lines if they don't like that if they
can't use that well then what then maybe
they're talking about something else
maybe they're talking about itineraries
maybe they're talking about locations
and that's what they should call them
that's my point and then the last one is
if geometry underlies mathematics and
that's going to be used or extrapolated
to physics well then mathematics is not
the language of physics period I mean
these people can't kid themselves and
say oh you know we're doing physics here
and they use words such as point in mind
and then say oh by the way they're not
defined we don't know what they what
these words mean but we're going to use
a many waste and
and you know we're just gonna our
theories are gonna be founded on them so
the guy says look who we have a point
here what are you talking about are you
talking about that little dot you just
put on the board no no it's a location
that's just a pictorial a pictorial
representation of a location so that's
telling you look we represent love with
a heart so every time you see a heart
you're supposed to think of love that's
what the guy's telling you or like I say
you know you wanna represent good
goodness you put an angel so you say
well that's an angel
no no but see don't look you're being
too literal the inner route present'
goodness you know you're going to heaven
or something so this is the problem the
problem is they put a dot and they say
it represents a location they put a line
and they say it represents an itinerary
a bunch of locations and that's where we
have the problem or a length or a
distance that's where the problem is
they're inconsistent first they're
inconsistent second these are not
geometric figures and all I'm saying is
if they're going to use if they're gonna
say that what they're intending is to
have a series of locations a series of
or yeah a series of locations or a
length or a distance or a bunch of
numbers you know a number line then they
should not use the word line they should
tell us exactly what they mean be
literal why use euphemisms why use
figures of speech why talk in parables
and in tongues send it like it is bunch
of locations movement displacement
length whatever you whatever you you
think it means
don't tell me line or order point and
mean something else okay with that
I'll see you next time and hopefully do
some research on line and point and go
crazy like
we'll see bye-bye